because I see what the media is doing
now I put a montage together they want
to call you a dictator you use the words
I am your retribution and now before
that you said if you've been wronged and
you used other words as well but I want
to be very very clear on this to be
clear do you in any way have any plans
whatsoever if reelected president to
abuse power to break the law to use the
government to go after people you mean
like they're using right now so in the
history of our
country what's happened to us again has
never happened before over nonsense over
nothing madeup charges I often say Al
Capone he was one of the greatest of all
time if you like criminals he was a mob
boss the likes of which Scarface they
call him and he got indicted once I got
indicted four times hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else